[Music]
so there's this book that i've been
meaning to read it's on my uh
uh to read list and it's called
jobs and so it's this premise that like
i i think was a professor some guy from
school of economics of london or
something like that and his whole like i
i again just remember i didn't research
this much uh his whole idea here is that
most jobs out there in the world like at
least in white color world
like it's it's just kind of unnecessary
like and and to summarize it it's like
take a company like hubspot amazon
twitter like
what would happen if you like laid off
two-thirds of the people like would it
would anything do we do we think
anything would change other than the
company would just make more profit and
this guy says in in most cases yeah it
would actually it would it would run
just fine and most of the jobs that you
have are just worthless
and i i kind of agree with him i i i i
agree i kind of agree
we don't have knowledge of of it other
than just personal experience but i
don't it does sound like it and it's
hard because there's no counterfactuals
so you don't get to run the test and
actually you know
run you can't split test and run run
both versions and see which one ends up
better
um
but i've had this inkling for a while
when we were getting acquired
and i
we were getting acquired by twitch and
as part of it they're like hey you got
to like you know basically like your
whole team is going to come in for a day
of interviews and that's going to decide
kind of like if we take your whole team
or not
and i had to do my interview as well and
so i'm going in there and they're like
you know the classic job interview
question a job interview structure is
like i ask you a bunch of questions for
95 of it and then the last five percent
of it i'm like so do you have any
questions for us and then you're
supposed to say something that's also
just you showing off
to like you know yeah show some other
strength of yours you know in a
different way
and um
and i had one genuine question i asked
it to every single person and they were
kind of like
taken aback
slash
they thought i was kind of a jerk
um
some people thought they reacted kind of
well like oh that's refreshing i don't
know i
hadn't really thought about it um but i
could tell other people were slightly
offended by my question and my question
was
i would say how many people work at
twitch and they would be like uh you
know i think we're at 1800 or 2000
people now
i said um
and how many people do you think i
forgot how i phrased it but it's
something like how many people do you
think twitch needs
to hit its goals
and i was like how many people do you
think should work here all right that's
how many people do work here how many
people do you think should work here
and people are like so i asked the ceo
this question too and he was he i give
him credit because
he's someone who like prioritizes the
truth over being right like getting it
right is way better than being right but
he's also like a kind of a fierce
debater so he's not just gonna like lay
down and be like oh you know yeah you're
right i changed my opinion about things
like so he like he took the question he
didn't like i would say nine out of ten
ceos would get quite offended by this
question because it basically implies
you've mismanaged the company by
bloating
it's a great question i would not be
offended
he was not offended either and he was
like
he was like that's a good question he's
i think like 2 200. so he was like yeah
i think we're a little short of what we
need to hit his goal and he's like he's
and then he his take was basically like
you know i'm not saying we have all the
right people or the most talented people
or that like there's not people here who
are under utilized or just kind of you
know the fat i wasn't really his point
it was like
i think we can be this much this
ambitious and to do that we would need
you know like 2200 awesome people like
working in unison um
i still think he was wrong i think we i
think you know the company kind of
operates
i would have followed up with a few
questions the first one would be okay
but do you think that you need to hire 2
200 people because you know that only 10
of them are going to be actually
value-add and you just have to hire the
the rest in order to find that 10
and then i would say and also is it
possible that you only that you think
you need 2 200 because you really only
need like 20 effort from all those
people and that's what your expectation
is and then finally how much does
redundancy come into play here how much
do people are you just paying them and
you just don't want to mention to them
but you're paying them to sit on the
bench and when the person next to them
quits they just are ready to roll right
uh yeah i didn't i didn't follow up that
hardcore about it uh but i think those
are you know very like valid valid
points and also you know one thing i i
kind of learned from him was like let's
take that redundancy one right it sounds
bad right it sounds like oh man you're
paying a bunch of people to kind of do
nothing just sit around no it's
insurance and he's like that was exactly
his take which was like
i think it was on speed i was
complaining how slow we were going and
he's like speed he's like going slow
sometimes a feature not a bug here and
he's like um or like innovation it's
like oh man we're not really innovating
everybody else isn't he didn't say this
outright but i you know i gathered this
through our conversations which is like
there are some things we're going to
innovate on but actually the optimal
strategy here is to let a bunch of
startups go out and try to innovate and
then if anything works either buy them
or clone them like that is actually the
best way for us to innovate it's like
it's free
we get way more experiments done by
super caliber you know super hungry
motivated people like startup founders
and their teams who are liz are focused
on just that one thing and they'll try
radical experiments that we would never
otherwise do and we don't have to fund
it but we can sit back and watch it and
then when we're ready we can either go
try to acquire them partner with them or
if they don't want to do any either of
those we can build our own and just use
our distribution and our brand
which you know we have if we have you
know x millions of users
then we should be able to outcompete
them from there
and my issue with i think that's
actually is the optimal strategy
i agree with emma i think on most things
i i imagine i would totally by the way i
should say i'm not putting words in his
mouth this is like
what i gathered from a bunch of bunch of
different conversations i'm sure he
would disagree with like you know
forty or fifty percent of what i just
said uh paraphrasing him poorly
yeah and it's just like your opinion on
your takeaway my take of his takes and i
uh i think i would agree with i bet i i
would agree with a lot of what he thinks
my issue is when you're like
a small company like under 50 people
you're all in it a lot of times you're
in it for a mission you're in it to
achieve something i think that you can
get away with just being in it because
people just like being in the thick of
it with their friends
uh like they just like the action
when you get a little bit bigger i think
it's less mission oriented and you're
and it's just a job but you still have
to put on this face like this to inspire
people and it kind of sucks because the
truth is is like well you know i i know
that you know a lot of you are only
working 40 and that's i'm okay with that
i baked that into this i know that a lot
of you aren't working at all but you're
really just here in case the guy next to
you quits and then hopefully you're
gonna train the next person and i know
that a lot of you want to innovate and
try these new things but that's not
really what we're gonna do we're gonna
keep doing the same just a little
bit better and then maybe every once in
a while i'm gonna have a team that makes
something totally new and i know all
this but just tough and figuring out how
to navigate and but have that like to
say what i just said but in a really
inspiring way or
unfortunately just lie you gotta lie
saying it is actually the best way yeah
just act you got to just act and pretend
um
and be a politician a little bit i find
that to be incredibly challenging but i
think it's incredibly necessary
yes
you're spot on um
you're spot on with that
you are spot on with
with what you just said do you think you
could do it
um
you know the i think the thing you said
i said have you ever heard of dunbar's
number
yeah what's it mean again so dunbar's
number is basically it's a 150 that's
the number and it's meant to represent
the number of different like how many
people know you know like how many
people you are familiar you like know
their name their face
how many people can one person know
actually right like somebody's like i
got six thousand friends like now well
you don't really know six thousand
people and so dunbar's number was was
used to be 150 it's like in a tribe you
could know 100 up up to 150 you could
know everybody in the tribe past 150 you
don't know everybody on the track
and then tools like social media and
stuff came out that kind of like it's
like a tool for the human body to like
do more so like you might be able to
know and keep up with more than 150
people now because facebook makes it
easy with a news feed and photos and
their name is listed there and whatever
you get to see it all the time
i think what you're saying is like your
version of dunbar's number which is 50
and it's like below this is dumb pars
dumpar's number i'll call it below 50
below 50.
um
the people who are there are like you
know down for the cause like yeah the
the the larger prior obviously they care
about themselves but like
a bigger like one of the top factors
either number one or number two can be
like the cause and then like or even
just like
just like you know like that kid who
said he wants to do hood red stuff with
his friends like that that could be the
cause like i just wanna i just
uh there was a viral video uh like uh
years ago and they interviewed this like
nine-year-old who um stole his
grandmother's car
and crashed it and the guy was like why
did you why did you steal her car that's
that was really bad of you and he goes
he goes i try to be good but sometimes i
just like doing hood rat stuff with my
friends like smoking cigarettes and
driving cars play the video play the
video bed you got to play that really
quick can you play it
along the way he ran over two mailboxes
hit two parked cars in a costco parking
lot and struck two moving cars near
walmart i want to do it because it's fun
fun to do bad things
drive into a car but did you know that
you could perhaps kill somebody yes but
i wanted to do her stuff for my friend
that's how i feel about startups the
youtube feature for this podcast just
took us to a whole new level already the
first one is great
second we need to pull the clip um
yeah just sometimes i wanted to reshape
with my friends and that needs to be a
sound clip ben that you can just play
when mirrored sam is talking about
something dumb that we're doing uh so
just just go ahead and cut that one out
that's the best part about that's the
best part about startups like i don't
care if it's ad tech i don't care if i'm
selling clothing i don't get like it
feels like
when you're when you're like pulling
off and you're like kind of fibbing
to people like yeah you know we've been
you know we really care about our
customers our team is it's like just
three of you and you know it's like
you're just like trying to pretend that
you're a big deal like that's hood rat
and i love doing that with my
friends but i wanted to do her stuff
with my friend
by the way have you struggled to do that
uh at now that you're a big enterprise
you know sas company that's like worth
billions of dollars and hood ratchet is
now frowned upon and you're like i just
yanked it i yanked it um you can't and
they're like you just yanked it sam why
did you do that we have a process for
that
because i definitely could think of like
two or three examples where i was
bragging about something i did that was
like the startup scrappy thing twitch
well i would just be like yeah like you
know
uh like for example there was like a
competitor
and
i like went to i talked to the founder
and i was like yeah like you know i
basically found out a bunch of their
numbers and i was like oh yeah you know
they're growing this fast this other
doing blah blah
and they're like well how do you know
that and i was like well i talked to my
i told them i was interested in blah
blah and they're like oh
[Music]
uh i was like what and they're like well
you know we just usually we don't
we don't do good wretch
basically it was like the the reward i
thought i was creating was like well
we're going to need to talk to legal and
also corp dev is going to have to you
know we have a guy whose job is to have
those conversations and we
we typically sign a letter of engagement
before like whatever it was like not the
exact example but like
things that in the startup when i was
doing my startup i would be so proud of
my hack about like whatever or like i
remember once i was negotiating a
partnership deal
and like
basically i was like really negotiating
for like every like every inch which as
a startup i used to love
winning a deal like doing it getting a
good deal for ourselves
and um
and they were just like you know they're
like you know what like we'd rather just
use our standard deal
and it's more favorable for him so he'll
be happy and we don't have to like you
know
let you like negotiate deal by deal on
these things and like you know in
general we don't really want you
negotiating directly with the person we
have like partnerships with people who
do that you're like yeah but they were
not negotiating
you're like the big lebowski guys like
dude you need a toe i'll get you a toe
i'll get you a toe if you need a toe
[Music]
you